humans are living through the most
prosperous safest time in human history
but there's one thing that's happening
right now that nobody's really talking
about and you as an individual have to
start paying attention to it's that
financial censorship and sanctions are
becoming the default if somebody
disagrees with a country a company or an
individual they start to actually
sanction them and somehow as we've
expanded the use of the terminology like
terrorism also financial sanctions are
getting normalized what used to be
reserved for people that were enemies at
war now all of a sudden is being used
over and over and over again just this
week here's a couple of examples the
united states is sanctioning russia as
they begin to invade ukraine china is
sanctioning u.s defense contractors for
selling arms to people that they don't
like
canada is literally sanctioning their
own citizens for doing things that they
don't agree with financial censorship is
becoming the standard and individuals
must wake up and start paying attention
now here's a little bit more about these
specific examples first canada anyone in
canada who supports or furthers the
freedom convoy on facebook instagram
twitter or any other social media
platform it's a target to have their
bank accounts frozen and insurance
policies nullified that is absolutely
insane it's basically saying that the
government is looking at anyone who
descends against their viewpoint and
they are going to use financial
sanctions literally a tool of war to go
and shut them up to go and sanction them
to freeze their assets to freeze their
bank accounts this is nasty nasty stuff
then if we look at china china has gone
after raytheon and lockheed because
they've sold equipment and services to
taiwan now of course you expect a
country to sanction another country but
the country to sanction individual
companies or individuals this stuff is
getting pretty crazy and so the
quintessential example is the united
states sanctioning russia we know that
united states has told russia over and
over and over again if you invade
ukraine we will sanction you and that's
exactly what's playing out now now of
course i'm not here to judge who's right
who's wrong i'm not here to judge
whether sanctions should be put on or
not ultimately what we are seeing is
that there is a movement in the world
that every single country that disagrees
with another country that disagrees with
a company or disagrees with a citizen
they are now normalizing financial
sanctions and censorship and so what you
can do at home is first you have to
educate yourself you have to understand
what financial censorship is to
understand why it's dangerous and you
also need to look at how you can fight
it yourself ultimately if you go down
that journey i think you'll arrive at
bitcoin bitcoin is a censorship
resistant technology it's a
decentralized digital currency that no
one controls and no one can create more
of it no one can freeze your assets no
one can stop you from transacting in a
peer-to-peer manner ultimately bitcoin
is freedom technology bitcoin is the
solution to financial censorship and so
my suggestion to you is go down the
rabbit hole go learn about this
technology as financial censorship and
sanctions become normalized you're gonna
want to have financial insurance bitcoin
is the chaos hedge bitcoin is the
solution bitcoin is inevitable and you
need to learn about it hey you did you
like this video great we make five of
them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time